esta es una manera efectiva de devolver
bienestar a la población o es más bien
populismo
gracias por la invitación pues mira son
las dos cosas porque resulta que esta
medida de devolver cosas que se han
incautado por actividades ilegales en
este caso el narcotráfico no es una
política que este gobierno está
implementando ya existía en el gobiernos
anteriores se realizaban decomisos se
realizaban acciones y se entregaba ese
dinero a través de diversas
instituciones
pero este gobierno se ha encargado de
hacer mucha propaganda y si se puede
considerar populista por ejemplo en
secciones anteriores un gran decomiso en
el
2007 un dinero un traficante relacionado
con el narcotráfico un empresario de
origen chino xiang ile de sein million
al cual se le decomisaron 205 millones
de dólares es el mayor decomiso en
efectivo en la historia de méxico y ese
dinero se devolvió a la sociedad a
través de tres instituciones se repartió
en tres grandes montos uno fue para la
propia fiscalía para combatir el
narcotráfico otro fue para la secretaría
de salud para poder apoyar hospitales y
un tercer monto de esos 205 millones de
dólares se fue a la judicatura que para
que organizara mejor la institución y yo
ejercer mejor la justicia es decir
tenemos que son actividades que siempre
se han hecho pero el gobierno particular
de lópez obrador ha hecho mucha
propaganda de hecho rifas que
anteriormente se entregaban directamente
a las instituciones y si se puede
considerar una medida populista desde
esa perspectiva
muy bien muy rápidamente le quiero
preguntar qué pasó entonces con las
últimas rifas de septiembre una historia
amarga con este tipo de movidas es el
sorteo del avión presidencial
los habitantes de josé maría morelos y
pavón en el estado de chiapas ganaron y
denunciaron que unas 28 familias
indígenas fueron amenazadas y
desplazadas por un grupo criminal por
negarse a comprar armas de alto calibre
con ese dinero
si desgraciadamente uno de los premios
eso ese fin tuvo que
finalmente estaban siendo extorsionadas
pero otro premio que no se entregó hubo
reclamos porque no se entregaron premios
u otros que no se sabe dónde quedó el
dinero porque nunca se especificó cómo
fue repartido los recursos de la rifa
del avión que no se reforme avión si no
se rezaba una cantidad en efectivo y en
efecto esta situación de que habitantes
fueran amenazados porque ahora tenían un
dinero que el crimen organizado quería
por reflejar las debilidades de estas
medidas no